(Degenerate laughing)
(Continues fake and forced laugh)
(Extreme coughing and laughing)
Oh sorry, didn't see you there. I was just laughing at my favorite moving image on the Internet.
Oh, you like GIFs too? H-How about this one?
(killmenow.jpg)
No? All right. Well how about this one, isn't that funny?
(swedish noises)
It's a moving image! It's the funniest thing on the internet!
(More fake laughter)
WHY AREN'T YOU LAUGHING??
*so much regret and pain in pewdiepie's soul*
"You guys are not going to believe this. [Stalin] has cancer." "Do you want to win all the giftcards down below?"
"Pewdiepie has died at the age of 69."
[Screams from hell]
Continue? That will be one demonetization, please
That's right, today we're going to discuss GIFs and why you're a complete low degenerate scumbag for using them.
mmmmmmmmmmmMMMMMM
That's right, I said it.
(Jack spedicy mimic attempt)
(Failed)
First thing you need to know about GIFs is that it's an acronym for:
God
I
Flipping
Suck
I added the last bit, just kidding guys. It's actually an acronym for:
Graphic Inter-change Formats
Hmm, interesting.
And second of all, more importantly, it's pronounced "gif". Okay, if you're calling a "jif..."
I don't know what to tell you. There must be something wrong with you. Are you straight-up loco?
(Angry 12 year-old voice) But Felix
The creator of GIFs calls them "jif"s so it has to be right to pronounce them "jif"s-
SSHHTTFFKKFF
Oh, okay, so just because you invented something means you're the literary scholar of how it's pronounced
What if I told you the creator of cars pronounced it
k a a a a r l l l l h h h ' s
Huh? Because the inventor of "KARLH"s pronounced it "KCH"
Stupid. Makes zero sense. You're as dumb as you look if you think that way.
Don't make me laugh
*Skrattas right away*
Stop, nope, not the GIFs. I can't, they're just too funny.
*Bass boost*
(Mental breakdown)
Do you even know what the verb of "jif" means?
Let's just entertain the idea of pronouncing a "jif". Do you do you know what "jif" means?
Do you know, you don't want to know, okay? Miss me with that gay shit.
*Demonetized*
I'm not discriminating for your strange sexual desires, but no. No 'jif'ing allowed. Okay, STOP IT.
Well, it seems like a bunch of you lobotomites or having trouble pronouncing the word "jif" so listen up.
You just called me a lobotomite!
This is-
[Inner demon speaking]
Because Dr. ThioJoe is going to lay down some righteous knowledge on you.
It's "jif."
It's pronounced "jif," and you know what? I'm not even saying it's
because that's the way the creator says it, that's not even a factor, just ignore that altogether.
"There is no 'J' in 'jif,' there's no reason to pronounce it like that!"
Oh, then what about "gin," "giraffe,"
"gel," "gym," "ginger," "general."
You must have just forgotten about those, right?
Hey Joe,
you seem a bit upset, could I give you a "jift?" Would you like me to "jift" do something?
Ha! Oh, that's - *proceeds to orgasm*
Oh I'm sorry, this, the G for the acronym stands for
"jraphics" or "graphics?"
[triggered sounds]
Let's see what other dumb arguments we have
Yeah, you lobotomize
There's about 1 million words in the English language and statistically
about 1.95% of them begin with a G, that's
19,500 words that begin with a G. On Wikipedia there's an article that's literally a list of words
where a hard G is used instead of a soft G
So the fact that you can actually create an article small enough to list them should clue you in a bit. Okay well
Okay, well let's examine that article.
Here's the same article, I found it, a list of English words where G is pronounced
exceptionally. Oh look, gif is in there! (*oof*-ing destroyed)
Wow, what a great article that you sourced, wow, that really proved your point really well, didn't it?
👏👏👏
There are 61 words on that list, let's even round it up to a hundred. A hundred out of 19,500 is 0.5%.
So you would rather argue that jiff is the exception to a rule that's followed
99.5% of the time instead of admitting that you never looked up the grammar rule in the first place.
*angry pewds* oh, just because statistically
it's less likely to be pronounced some way means that it is pronounced that way.
Yeah, that definitely makes sense. According to that logic,
all these words should be pronounced jecko, jeek, jeese
It's the same idea, right? Now "it's less likely to pronounce that way" you JOOFUS,
you JUMMY,
you JUM-JUM, you JUB me don't spank your jubby butt?
*realization what the oof he just said*
"Well it stands for graphics interchange format so the G must be hard!"
This is such a stupid argument that it instantly makes you sound like an idiot.
No it doesn't, shut up.
I made a poll on Twitter to see what you guys thought was the best way to pronounce it
Oh look, most of you think it's pronounced with a hard G. So that means statistically
it's correct, right? And, of course,
Wikipedia is the most trusted site of all time to get your sources from
What if we look up gif in an actual dic(k)tionary?
Oh look. What's the first thing that shows up? Gif with a hard G.
Wow, that really sure was hard, wasn't it?
That's right, got you guys hard on (iykwim) the gif issue, haters gonna hate amirite?
Sure glad we got that settled
Now let's move on to the actual issue of the gifs
Gifs have been around for a very long time, over 25 years
It started off as cute little baby dancing.
Wow look at that, that's-you remember that one? (sure do)
Only 90s kids will remember
(again with that *oof*-ing fake laughter)
How about the peanut butter jelly banana that was funny, right?
Gifs used to be so cute and so innocent
Look at this, they were used to make websites look good (oh god why)
I remember I made a website just adding a bunch of gifs
(ah, the good old daaays♪)
Oh look at all these great butterflies!
You don't see gifs like that anymore, you just don't.
Look at the amazing frame rate of this one, wow, it's like I'm truly there.
Love Star Wars gifs, they're the best.
Well now, guess what it is now. It's cancer, it's just cancer.
So much cancer. If you posted a gif in the last 7 days
I got news for ya,
ur mom gay. That's just how it is. I'm sorry.
I know what you're thinking, how did we go from this
to this?
(video begins) "Ever shared this?
Or this?
Nothing like a good reaction gif, right?
But you've probably noticed most popular ones are of black people being dramatic.
This (is not digital blackface)
is free real estate
Guys, it is
T I M E  T O  S T O P
I don't understand why people are so fun of using gifs. They're not funny
They rarely are funny, or even chuckle worthy
But it's still, they're spread around everywhere, like a disease.
I tried myself to look up some cringy examples of people using gifs
and the only thing that showed up was people cringing.
Which is cringy in itself.
You are what you're trying to portray that you're against.
WAKE UP
Sharing a gif of you cringing is cringy
(Marzia in the background) stop hating ;_;
Go back and post gifs!
Can't believe this, my own GF
(Marzia) You mean your own GIF?
(pun worthy of eyeroll)
GO
It's time to stop
Do you know why gifs are so popular? Because of the toilet of the internet
No I'm not talking about my channel, I'm talking about tumblr
It's as if you need at least ten images at all times to stimulate your brain
to distract you from the fact that you are an angsty depressed teenager, that's tumblr essentially
Congratulations everyone.
When someone greets you by name, and you don't recognize them
(holy heck that was soo fricking funny I'm ROFLMAO'ing on the floor right now)
[weird grunts]
When you're seated between two people who are fighting
(gif speeds up in an attempt to make it funny)
If this was what YLYL would look like, the internet would be a sad place, even sadder than it is now
So relatable oh my *gawd*
When you unexpectedly run into a friend you just heard a rumor about
*about to lose his will to live*
Do you have any form of character by yourself?
Do you really need celebrities to portray your emotions and words?
You literally you're just so empty
that you can't even express yourself without using the image in a video (incoming ear rape)
and a text by someone else.
Now I know it's like an argument that "oh, you're stealing memes and gifs, it's the same thing"
but you're not just stealing the joke. You're stealing the whole character of another person.
It's pathetic
BFT FELFX WF'RF JST HFVING FFN
You're not allowed to have fun, not on this channel
*skratta*
Buzzfeed, of course, is also a huge problem to why gifs are so popular
Can you imagine studying for years to become a journalist
to then work on a new site of writing articles called
"19 Things Even Healthy People Do That Are Actually Bad For You"
(gotta get that capitalization right)
spend up to 75 thousand dollars to get your degree
to then being told "Hey, this is a great article and what you wrote was really great,
but can we just add more pictures of celebrities that are moving in there
because your words were just not adequate enough?"
(pewds making sassy voice) "Ignoring your body and refusing to make doctor appointments"
pfffff sssssss
*DUN* that's just s
If you're not convinced by my ideas why gifs are bad, don't worry.
There are straight-up facts to explain this as well.
Gifs were originally popular because they were efficient.
Gif uses an image compressing called L Z Wee,
which stands for
LOL ZORZ WOW
Just kidding. Sometimes I just like to make stuff up.
Elzey Wee
It's a lossless compression algorithm that lets you download large image
quickly even if you have a slow bandwidth
👏👏👏
Great, yes. It was great 20 years ago. Gifs have now been surpassed by its superior
PEE ENGIE
(little crybabies) "But I want moving images!"
We all know that gits have been around for a very long time, it's an old format
But now that people popularize it by adding images and moving images to it,
that's when it's become clearly an outdated format.
Don't believe me? I'm gonna link two examples in the description just click on them, alright?
I have a pretty fast internet, and these gifs are not downloading unless
I open them individually, they'll load quicker that way
The reason why the video is quicker than the the gif
is because it's around two megabytes instead of the gif which is 14 megabyte
DAMN DANIEL
The video can also start streaming and doesn't need to download the whole thing to start playing the video
while the gif needs to download the whole file to display properly
BUT WHY IS THIS?
(confused pewds and an invisible person)
Because of video compression, that's right!
If this setup I have with the camera, for example, takes very little space on your computer
or at least when on my computer because
Simple background, I'm not moving a lot.
The way the video compression works is that it takes only the images that changes in into account
It doesn't keep having to re-download this background for example
Unless the background changes which leads to a lot less data to be wasted. Yay!
But if you start adding a bunch of stuff moving on the screen, and if I go all crazy
And you add a bunch of confetti and stuff you'll quickly see that the quality of the video goes down quite a bit
But this is how it's possible that we can have so many videos on YouTube and so long. Thank you
Thanks to the efficiency of video compression, so many things are made possible. Hooray!
👏👏👏👏
It's also very cool when video compression fails
♪Datamoshing cool, datamoshing great♪
♪Justin Bieber I move him with my face♪
♪Then use it for an art show, use it for a piece♪
♪Projected on a apple, projected on a peach♪
♪Find me on the internet, I'm making gifs♪
Damn it, stop with the gifs!
But pewds, not everyone has bad internet so we don't need to have an efficient model s-"
There's no reason to purposely be inefficient, okay?
There is a better solution. That's right,
HTML5 elements!
AAAAHHHHHHHH
It's got autoplay, it can loop if you want to, look at this beauty
Oh, plays right away even though the whole thing hasn't buffered yet
It has sound, it has volume control
You can pause it, you can choose to loop it if you want to, you can adjust the volume
You can easily download it, and you can go fullscreen with it and the coding for it is also very simple
get dunked boi
HTML5 elements everybody!
That's right, gif, you just got schooled, oh snap!
Y'all just got served on the gif topic, what else argument do you have for using that garbage?
Okay, everybody, now we can finally agree on at least two things, alright?
It's pronounced gif and you need to stop using them
I know it's sad, but all things must come to an end at some point and I think it's time that we finally retired
this outdated format
I know, how am I going to express my life if I can't express myself through Ariana Grande gifs?
I know it's going to be tough,
but you can get through this, I believe in you.
Just think about what Ariana said herself
"I just had a bone taken out of my skull. how's ur day."
That's right. That's how I got out of my gif addiction.
So stop it, stop with this garbage
I don't want to see a single gif meme ever again in my entire life!
Wait what's this? That's hilarious!
HYEEEH
*gasp*
huehuehue
FFFFFFFFFFFF